bonjour à tous suite ce matin du projet
de loi de finances pour 2011
ce matin les sénateurs examinent les
crédits de la mission outre-mer depuis
plusieurs années les crédits de cette
mission était en hausse
environ + 1 44 ans mais cette année il
va y avoir un inversement de tendance
puisque le budget du ministère de
l'outremer va subir une légère baisse de
2,3 pour cent atteignant ainsi un
milliard 980 millions d'euros
même si cette baisse reste relative les
débats s'annoncent donc vifs dans
l'hémicycle cette année le ministère de
l'outre-mer a choisi de centrer son
activité sur deux missions l'aide au
logement et l'aide aux entreprises
à noter également le coup de rabot fait
sur les niches fiscales d'outre-mer
reste cependant un secteur épargné celui
du logement social tout de suite donc
direction l'hémicycle pour le détail du
budget de l'outre-mer 2011 très bonne
séance
le sénat va maintenant examiner les
crédits de la mission outre-mer et dans
cet examen la parole est d'abord au
rapporteur spécial de la commission des
finances monsieur marc massion
vous avez la parole monsieur le
rapporteur spécial monsieur le président
madame la ministre
cher collègue reporter la commission des
lois de l'économie des affaires sociales
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances le cher collègue notre
présentation des crédits de la mission
outre-mer pour 2011 s'articule en deux
parties tout d'abord je vous présenterai
le cadrage globale du budget de la
mission et son premier programme puis
eric doligé vous présentera de manière
plus détaillée l'évolution des crédits
du second programme est rapidement les
articles rattachés à la mission avant
d'entrer dans le vif du sujet je
souhaiterais faire un point sur l'état
d'application de la loi pour le
développement économique des outre-mer
la lodeom votée le 27 mai 2009 si la
grande majorité des décrets
d'application sont aujourd'hui par u 18
mois après l'adoption de la lodeom trois
mesures restent toutefois encore
inapplicable faute de décret
d'application
l'aide au fret pour les entreprises le
groupement d'intérêt public censé régler
le problème de l'indivision et le
dispositif de transparence des prix
pratiqués par les transporteurs aériens
outre ces mesures de nombreux décrets
d'application ne sont pas parus que dans
le courant de l'année 2010 ce qui
explique que les dispositifs concernés
ne produisent pas encore leur plein
effet revenons-en au projet de budget
2011 qui constitue une rupture par
rapport aux budgets des trois années
précédentes
en effet pour la première fois depuis la
stabilisation de sa maquette en 2008 les
crédits affectés à la mission outre-mer
diminue dans le projet de loi de
finances 2011 par rapport aux crédits
votés dans la loi de finances initiale
pour 2010 la baisse reste toutefois
limitée puisqu'elle s'élève à 0,5 pour
cent en autorisations d'engagement et à
2,3 pour cent en crédits de paiement
cette contraction des dotations porte
exclu
il ment sur les crédits du programme
conditions de vie outre mer et sera
détaillé par eric doligé en dépit de ce
constat le sort de la mission outre mer
restait enviable au sein du budget
général de l'état
en effet entre 2008 et 2011 notamment le
montant des autorisations d'engagement
de la mission globalement augmenté de 22
9% et celui décrit paiement de 15 %
une rupture peut également être relevé
en matière de dépenses fiscales
rattachées à la mission outre-mer
en effet depuis 2008 le montant des
niches fiscales rattachées à la mission
n'a cessé de progresser
à cet égard là le dr m'a conduit à une
augmentation globale de ce montant
puisque les niches créé et comptait
légèrement plus que les niches supprimés
sur aiguë
les mesures que nous avons voté la
semaine dernière dans la première partie
du projet de loi de finances 2011 est
celle que nous examinerons la semaine
prochaine dans sa deuxième partie
devrait conduire pour la première fois
alors diminution mais celle ci ne
pourrait être constaté qu'en 2012
puisque la réduction des niches fiscales
portera sur les revenus 2011
en 2011 la dépense fiscale outre-mer
continue donc d'augmenter quoiqu'à un
rythme râlons elle progressera de 1,9
pour cent entre 2010 et 2011 pour
s'établir à 3,4 milliards d'euros
revenons-en au premier des deux
programmes de la mission consacrée à
l'emploi outre-mer deux éléments majeurs
se dégagent de son analyse d'une part et
je dirais comme d'habitude les crédits
consacrés au remboursement à la sécurité
sociale des exonérations de charges
spécifiques à l'outre-mer sont soupe
budgétisé il devrait manquer d'après les
besoins identifiés par les organismes de
sécurité sociale 63 millions d'euros en
il est donc à craindre comme c'est
arrivé en 2007 en 2008 et en 2009
que le gouvernement ne soit amené à
ouvrir en cours de gestion ou par la loi
de finances rectificative les crédits
nécessaires
la commission des finances vous
présentera donc un amendement pour
remédier partiellement à cette sous
budgétisation l'amendement propose de
transférer les crédits consacrés à l'
agence de santé de wallis et futuna vers
les exonérations de charges sociales
je vous rassure tout de suite et
notamment notre collègue sénateur de
wallis et futuna
l'objectif n'est pas du tout de remettre
en cause cet établissement mais de
soulever le problème de sa gestion par
le ministère de l'outre-mer qui n'est
pas en mesure de le satisfaire de
manière satisfaisante
il nous semble que cette gestion devrait
être assuré normalement par le ministère
en charge de la santé
mais j'aurai d'ailleurs l'occasion de
développer ce point lors de la
présentation de l'amendement d'autre
part concernant le programme hamp autres
maires on constate que si les crédits
augmentent c'est en raison de la montée
en puissance du service militaire adapté
le sm ans ce dispositif d'intégration
des jeunes
un marin non diplômés à travers une
formation citoyenne militaire et
professionnels a fait ses preuves par le
passé de sorte que le président de la
république a annoncé en 2009 le
doublement du nombre de jeunes
bénéficiaires nous avions formulé des
inquiétudes sur ce point
en constatant que le budget consacré aux
et ouais c'est ma ne connaissait pas
parallèlement un doublement
le projet de loi de finances est de
nature à apaiser nos inquiétudes
d'une part les crédits consacrés aux
essais mao augmente fortement + 45% en
autorisations d'engagement et 37,1 %
crédits de paiement pour s'élever à 201
millions d'euros en autorisations
d'engagement et 181 millions en crédits
de paiement
d'autre part nous savons désormais que
les nouveaux publics du cema ne seront
plus que des jeunes non diplômés mais
des personnes parfois diplômés en
situation de chômage de longue durée
elles recevront des formations d'une
durée plus courte que les actuels
volontaire
du sénat ce qui permet de doubler le
nombre de bénéficiaires du dispositif
sans doubler les moyens qui lui sont
affectés
il faudra toutefois dans nos contrôles à
venir vérifier que le dispositif du
nouveau et c'est ma est aussi efficace
que l'ancien et je laisse la parole à
eric doligé pour vous présenter les
autres orientations de ce projet de
budget monsieur le rapporteur spécial
la parole est maintenant monsieur eric
doligé rapporteur spécial de la
commission des finances la parole
monsieur le rapporteur spécial
merci monsieur le président madame le
ministre ce président de la commission
chers collègues rapporteur au pluriel
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs après
mon collègue marc massion qui vous a
présenté le cadrage globale du budget de
la mission et de son premier programme
et bien j'en viens au second programme
de la mission intitulée conditions de
vie outre mer est en réalité composé
d'actions très disparates
je vais donc me concentrer sur les
points les plus marquants les crédits du
programme diminue assez fortement en
2011 -6% en autorisations d'engagement
et -10 4 en crédits de paiement deux
raisons expliquent principalement cette
baisse d'une part les crédits consacrés
au fonds exceptionnel d'investissement
le fbi
créé par la lodeom pour participer aux
investissements des collectivités
territoriales d'outre-mer passe de 40 à
10 millions d'euros
le gouvernement justifie cette baisse
par la sortie du plan de relance
je relève toutefois que la création du
fci a précédé le plan de relance et
qu'il était alors dès sa création de thé
de 40 millions d'euros
la deuxième raison qui explique la
diminution des crédits et la fin des
versements au titre de l'ex fonds pour
la reconversion de l'économie de
polynésie française prévue par la
convention du 25 juillet 96 dans le
cadre de l'arrêt des essais nucléaires
cette fin était programmée pour 2011 est
conduite à une baisse des crédits de 30
millions d'euros
en autorisations d'engagement et de 46
ans cp en matière de logement on ne peut
que constater que les effets de la
lodeom ne se font pas encore sentir
seuls six mille deux cents logements
neufs ont été construits en 2009 pour
des besoins estimés depuis déjà fort
longtemps 45 mille logements par an
outre la crise économique
deux raisons expliquent ce retard d'une
part les décrets d'application de la
lodeom pour le recentrage de la
défiscalisation sur le logement social
ne sont parus qu'au début de cette année
2010 les opérateurs ont donc attendu la
mise en place du nouveau dispositif qui
devrait monter en charge progressivement
d'autre part la nouvelle possibilité de
cumul de la défiscalisation et des
crédits de la ligne budgétaire unique
pour le financement des opérations de
logement nécessite un temps d'adaptation
des procédures beaucoup d'informations
remonte du terrain afin de nous signaler
des difficultés de mise en oeuvre de la
nouvelle réglementation issue de la
lodeom tant au niveau local qu'au niveau
du ministère des finances
nous avons donc besoin d'être rassuré
sur ce point madame la ministre nous
proposerons des amendements en la
matière d'après les informations que
vous nous avez transmises
les premiers chiffres disponibles pour
2010 indique un décollage par rapport à
espérons le bien évidemment derniers
éléments de ce programme la réforme du
dispositif de continuité territoriale
qui regroupe 51,6 millions d'euros de
crédits elle n'a pas encore pu entrer
pleinement en vigueur des décrets
d'application de la lodeom n'étant pas
rue qu'il ya une dizaine de jours madame
la ministre vous pourrez probablement
nous donner des informations plus
détaillées sur ce point dans concernant
la réforme de la continuité territoriale
le nouveau fonds de continuité
territoriale doit par ailleurs être géré
par l'ademe qui est l'agent de
l'outre-mer pour la mobilité
seul opérateur de la mission dont le nom
et les compétences ont été modifiés dont
les crédits vent quadruples et pour cela
en 2011 or nous avons très peu
d'informations sur cette agence dont la
performance était jusqu'à aujourd'hui
assez limité c'est pourquoi la
commission a confié à la cour des
comptes une mission de contrôle sur la
dom en application de l'article 58 de la
lolf
j'en viens au deux articles rattachés
l'article 77 réforme la dotation globale
de développement économique la dgd e
versés chaque année par l'état à la
polynésie française
cette dotation d'un montant 6 251
millions d'euros par an fonctionne mal
elles n'existent qu'en vertu d'une
convention passée entre l'état et le
territoire et malgré cinq avenant en
sept ans c'est à dire presque autant de
changement de gouvernement dans la même
période le contrôle de l'utilisation des
fonds s'est avéré très difficile
l'article 77 propose donc une réforme
bienvenus en créant à la place de la dgd
1,3 dotation distinctes dont le montant
total sera égal au montant actuel
versées aux territoires
d'une part une dotation globale
d'autonomie qui sera attribuée à la
collectivité de la polynésie française
pour financer son fonctionnement sur le
modèle de la dgf
elle évoluera d'ailleurs au même rythme
que la dr d'autre part une dotation
d'investissement versé directement par
l'état aux communes polynésiennes
c'est là la nouveauté bien évidemment en
effet comme l'avait relevé nos collègue
christian cointat et bernard frimat dans
un rapport fait au nom de la commission
des lois le financement des communes par
la collectivité polynésienne engendre
actuellement effets pervers et clientes
et enfin un concours financier dans les
modalités resteront fixés par une
convention mais qui servira uniquement à
financer les investissements
structurants de la polynésie française
cette réforme nous paraît aller dans le
bon sens elle doit permettre de
pérenniser
l'effort de l'état envers la polynésie
de l'inscrire dans la loi et non dans
une convention sujette à interprétation
de distinguer les fonds versés pour le
fonctionnement et pour l'investissement
et enfin de remédier au problème de
financement des communes polynésiens la
commission des finances vous proposera
toutefois d' adopter deux amendements
qui précise et stabilise le dispositif
propose
par le gouvernement quatre autres
articles sur lesquels la commission des
finances ne propose pas de modifications
ont été ajoutées à l'assemblée nationale
l'article 77 10 doit permettre à l'état
de céder à titre gratuit des terrains de
son domaine privé pour la réalisation
d'opérations de logements ou
d'aménagements publics
je ne suis pas certain que ce dispositif
qui existe déjà en guyane soit à même de
résoudre les problèmes de disponibilité
du foncier que l'outre-mer rencontre
mais il constitue toutefois un sérieux
pas en avant
l'article 77 terre doit permettre de
faciliter la mise en oeuvre du
dispositif des aides à la rénovation des
hôtels que nous avons voté dans
lanaudière l'article 77 kw à terre quant
à lui met en oeuvre un plan d'apurement
des dettes sociales des entreprises
hôtelières dans les antilles
la commission des finances a validé ce
dispositif mais souhaite toutefois ne
pas multiplier ce type d'apurement et
que le paiement des cotisations sociales
par les entreprises d'outre-mer reste le
droit commun enfin l'article 77 15
pièces doit permettre le déploiement de
la télévision numérique terrestre la tnt
en outre-mer tout en préservant la
diversité culturelle des petites chaînes
de télévision sous le bénéfice de ces
divers opéras observations et des
amendements qu'elle vous êtes présentera
la commission des finances vous propose
d'adopter les crédits de la mission
outre-mer ainsi que les cinq articles
rattachés à cette mission sur rapporteur
spécial devait donner maintenant la
parole à madame anne marie payet
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires sociales vous avez la
parole madame le rapporteur
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues
les crédits de la mission outre-mer pour
2011 ont été excellemment présenté par
eric doligé et marc massion non
rapporteurs spéciaux et je les en
remercie
la commission des affaires sociales a
donné un avis favorable à leur adoption
et je n'évoquerai aujourd'hui que
quelques-uns des sujets qui la
concernent plus directement le
gouvernant a annoncé il ya deux ans et
demi un plan santé pour l'outre-mer et
le cio m a parlé de faire de la santé
une activité de pointe le cio m a parlé
de faire de la santé une activité de
pointe outre mer certes le déploiement
des études médicales est en cours et le
numerus clausus a été légèrement
augmenté mais les actions mettent du
temps à se concrétiser sur le terrain
ainsi que l'on prenne l'exemple de la
télémédecine des réseaux de télé
enseignement est de visioconférence de
la mise aux normes sismiques des
hôpitaux de la révision des coefficient
géographique et de la valorisation des
surcoûts relatifs aux activités
déséquilibré ou encore de la lutte
contre la drépanocytose
on nous indique qu'ils seront soit
instruit ultérieurement soit dans le
meilleur des cas qu'ils feront l'objet
d'un état des lieux d'un bilan général
ou d'études sur ce point justement 20000
euros ce qui est dérisoire était prévu
pour 2010 pour financer une étude afin
de caractériser les décès infantiles des
dom et les comparer à ceux de la
métropole
est il besoin de rappeler que les taux
de mortalité infantile et maternelle
sont dramatiquement élevé votre mère en
étant vraiment encore à devoir
caractérisé ces décès plus largement la
première tranche du plan hôpital 2012
n'est destiné qu'à hauteur de 2,2 pour
cent à l'outre-mer
ce qui me semble loin d'être suffisant
au regard des besoins
ma première question madame la ministre
est donc la suivante quelles actions
concrètes seront menées en 2011 sur le
terrain pour améliorer la santé publique
outre mer nous examinerons tout à
l'heure un amendement sur les ventes de
tabac dans les dom
qui va me semble-t-il en ce sens le
logement est le second sujet que je
souhaite aborder
je ne reviendrai pas sur le diagnostic
et sur l'état des lieux que tout le
monde connaît et partage quelques
éléments sont certes positifs
le décret sur la surcharge foncière a
été adopté récemment et les crédits
destinés au fra fut sont en nette
augmentation en 2011
toutefois deux problèmes majeurs
subsistent les engagements de la lb eu
sont stables en 2011 mais les crédits de
paiement sont en baisse de 10% le
gouvernement assure que la programmation
sera respectée on peut s'en étonner
alors que les crédits 2010 sont presque
entièrement consommée comment dans ces
conditions résoudre la crise aiguë du
logement avec des crédits en baisse le
nouveau dispositif de défiscalisation du
logement social pose encore de nombreux
problèmes d'application concrète qui
risque de retarder les opérations que ce
soit en termes d'agrément de procédures
ou de cumul avec la sbu
le rapport de nos collègues députés gaël
yanno et claude bartolone du 29
septembre dernier sur l'application de
la lodeom est très éclairant à cet égard
notre commission a déposé plusieurs
amendements pour fluidifier les
procédures il constitue un premier pas
un signal et j'espère qu'ils pourront
être largement adopté nos territoires
connaissent des contraintes fortes liées
au climat à la géographie parfois à
l'histoire si bien que l'action publique
est déterminante pour permettre à tous
de se loger
madame la ministre vous avez rencontré
le 12 novembre dernier les représentants
des bailleurs sociaux
j'ai également auditionné certains
d'entre eux et ils sont très inquiet
pouvez vous nous indiquer les
conclusions que vous avez tiré de cette
réunion et les mesures que le
gouvernement compte adopter pour
améliorer la situation
avant de conclure juste quelques mots
sur le rsa il va enfin entrer en vigueur
le 1er janvier prochain et doit
coexister durant une certaine période
avec le rsca qui avait été créé à la
suite de la crise sociale du printemps
2009 l'hamamélis il ne me semble pas que
le décret prolongeant le est resté a été
publié
quand comptez vous le faire et quelles
dispositions contient date il exactement
il serait tout de même préférable que
les bénéficiaires qui devront choisir de
manière irréversible entre eux les deux
prestations d'une part et les
gestionnaires à café cgss d'autre part
soit au courant suffisamment longtemps à
l'avance en conclusion une dernière
question la répartition des crédits du
fonds exceptionnel d'investissement du
plan hôpital 2012 de l'anah ou encore de
l'ancien dotation de continuité
territoriale ne tient pas compte de
l'importance démographique de chacun des
deux hommes comment expliquer que la
réunion avec huit cent mille habitants
reçoit parfois moins voire nettement
mois que d'autres départements outre-mer
a besoin de politique stable et durable
d'importantes annonces ont été faites
par le cio m voici maintenant un an
j'espère que 2011 permettra d'avancer
avec courage sur la voie des réformes je
vous remercie
merci madame le rapporteur la parole est
maintenant à monsieur claude lise
rapporteur pour avis de la commission de
l'économie n'avait la parole monsieur le
rapporteur
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
en réponse à la grave crise qu'ont connu
deux outre-mer au début de l'année 2009
le gouvernement a fait des annonces
nombreuses et importantes dans le cadre
de la loi pour le développement
économique des outre-mer et du conseil
interministériel de l'outre-mer ces
annonces ont suscité des espoirs
importants dans nos eaux outre-mer cela
a été dit mais elle tarde vraiment
apporté les effets attendus à cause des
retards ou de l'absence de mise en
oeuvre effective des mesures
correspondantes
au vu de l'évolution non seulement des
crédits de la mission outre-mer mais de
l'effort budgétaire global prévu pour
je ne peux que faire part d'une certaine
déception la déception est encore plus
grande quand on analyse les autres
mesures du projet de loi de finances qui
concerne l'outre-mer notamment l'article
13 que notre euro a semblé adopter la
semaine dernière et qui supprime le
dispositif de défiscalisation dans le
secteur du photovoltaïque s'agit
pourtant de l'un des secteurs les plus
prometteurs pour le développement
endogène de l'outre-mer au lieu du
développement
douze jeunes précisément temps évoquée
dans les débats sur la lodeom
j'ai le sentiment madame la ministre que
l'on se retrouve plutôt dans une logique
de mal développement endogène je ne
m'attarderai pas sur les crédits de la
mission outre-mer inscrits au projet de
loi de finances pour 2011 dont
l'évolution a déjà été présentée par
nous raconter spéciaux je relève
cependant qu'il diminue de 0 5% en
autorisations d'engagement et de 2,3
pour cent crédits de paiement il s'agit
cela a été souligné de la première
diminution réellement affichée depuis
trois ans les outre-mers participe donc
à la politique de rigueur
cela n'est j'en conviens pas anormal je
considère cependant qu en toute équité
l'effort qu'il aurait demandé devraient
davantage tenir compte de leur mal
développement et de la situation
économique et sociale très préoccupante
qui est la leur je souhaite évoquer plus
longuement une problématique essentielle
de nos outre-mer le logement près de
soixante mille demandes de logements
sociaux sont aujourd'hui en attente dans
les quatre départements d'outre-mer
rapporté à la population de l'hexagone
ce chiffre correspond à près de deux
millions de demandes en attente
c'est dire l'ampleur de l'enjeu le
conseil interministériel de l'outre-mer
avait annoncé que le niveau de la ligne
budgétaire unique serait maintenue dans
le cadre du projet de loi de finances
pour 2011 le niveau de la ligne
budgétaire unique est bien maintenue en
autorisations d'engagement et je m'en
réjouis
les crédits sont par contre en recul de
près de 10% crédits de paiement en
matière de logement social les qualités
non recule même de près de 34%
cette diminution serait justifiée nous
dit-on par la sous consommation
chronique des crédits de la lbu alors je
m'étonne de cet argument de la mesure où
l'on constate en tout cas dans le
département de la martinique que les
crédits prévus en 2010 sont déjà
consommés à hauteur de 99 hausse en ce
moment par ailleurs les dispositifs de
défiscalisation dans le logement social
mis en place par la lodeom n'a pas fait
pour lui
de son efficacité à ce jour il n'a
permis la construction effective d'aucun
logement social seul 829 logements ont
été agréés au titre de ce dispositif
entre la fin de l'année 2009 et le 30
septembre 2010 ce bilan est notamment
liée à des difficultés d'application
d'une part les modalités d'instruction
des dossiers différentes revues et
défiscalisation d'autres partis surtout
les modalités de cumul entre élevé une
défiscalisation pose aujourd'hui
problème cela a été dit alors que la
possibilité de cumul avait été
clairement évoquée par votre
prédécesseur lors des débats sur la
lodeom
vous avez publié madame la ministre une
circulaire le 1er juin dernier qui
s'éloigne donc de l'esprit de la loi
je ne peux que le regretter car cela
freine la réalisation de certaines
opérations sans que je souhaite pour
autant je le précise que le cumul
prennent un caractère systématique
je sais que vous avez reçu donc le 12
novembre dernier les bailleurs sociaux
donc à mon tour je vous demande ce que
vous comptez prendre comme disposition
cours des prochaines semaines afin que
ce dispositif s'avère réellement
efficace plus généralement quelles
mesures prendre et vous dans les
prochains mois afin d'opérer une réelle
relance de la politique du logement
social pour répondre à l'ampleur des
besoins tant sur le plan social que sur
le plan économique
en conclusion la commission de
l'économie a malgré mes réserves émis un
avis favorable à l'adoption des crédits
de la mission première pour 2011 si
monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est maintenant monsieur
christian cointat rapporteur pour avis
de la commission des lois
la parole monsieur le rapporteur oui
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
albert einstein nous a pris les charmes
de la relativité
aussi devons nous être conscient que
dans un monde de disette financière ou
le budget ne cesse de se contracter par
phases successives
tel un cycle sans fin le statu quo peut
apparaître comme une forme de
progression
tel est le cas du moins pour l'essentiel
du budget destiné à l'outre-mer tant au
niveau de la mission outre-mer
qu'alléchant global cela souligne une
nouvelle fois la volonté manifeste de
l'état d'assurer un effort soutenu pour
l'ensemble des collectivités
ultramarines
nous pouvons donc manifesté une certaine
satisfaction
ou plutôt pour être exact une
satisfaction relative la seule la notion
d'économie dont on nous rebat en
permanence les oreilles au point de
perdre de vue la finalité du budget qui
consiste à financer du mieux possible
des dépenses jugées utiles expression de
choix politique comporte des effets
pervers en masquant souvent par une
lecture immédiate des résultats à moyen
et long termes pour gagner quelques sous
entend on dire alors qu'il ne s'agit pas
de gain et d'un renoncement à agir on
peut par des malencontreux coup de rabot
financiers se priver des objectifs
voulus alphonse allais 10g sous la forme
d'une boutade il faut demander plus à
l'impôt et moins au contribuable
en réalité ce n'est pas une boutade il
faut sortir du carcan dogmatique qui
nous étouffe et empêche une utilisation
optimale des crédits alors on pourra
dépenser moins tout en agissant plus je
n'entrerai pas dans le détail des
crédits prévus pour la mission outre-mer
qui ont été excellemment présenté par
nos collègues invention et doligé de la
commission des finances ne rapporteurs
spéciaux
je me concentrerai simplement sur deux
points auxquels votre commission des
lois est attaché à savoir les
instruments de la dépense et la gestion
de celle-ci
en effet il ne suffit pas de disposer
des moyens de l'action
encore faut-il les utiliser au mieux des
besoins et de la façon la plus adaptée à
ces nécessités or dans ces domaines
il semble que des progrès substantiels
pourrait être fait le premier point
j'aborderai concerne les indicateurs de
performance ces derniers s'avèrent
rudimentaire ou par sévère au point de
ne pouvoir remplir pleinement leurs
fonctions d'information et d'évaluation
compte tenu de l'ampleur de l'effort
budgétaire et fiscale déployés en
particulier en matière de
défiscalisation et d'allègement des
charges sociales il serait opportun que
l'état s'assure de manière beaucoup plus
approfondi de l'efficacité économique et
social des différents instruments
financiers utilisés comme de l'emploi
des crédits attribués
or des intérêts des interrogations mais
ses collègues subsistent à ce niveau
certes une évaluation est présenté mais
elle est ni suffisante ni très
significative à cet égard et ne permet
pas au parlement de mesurer clairement
le rendement global est relatif des
choix effectués ni de connaître leur
impact réel par rapport aux objectifs
poursuivis
cette question est en définitive liées à
celles de la réorganisation de
l'administration centrale chargée de
l'outre-mer et qui constitue le deuxième
point que je souhaite soulever dans
cette brève intervention
interministériel par nature la politique
de l'état en faveur des populations et
des collectivités d'outre-mer requiert
impérativement une forte coordination et
une autorité de pilotage capable
d'exercer cette coordination est de
veiller à l'intégration correcte de la
dimension ultramarines dans toutes les
politiques publiques et par tous les
départements ministériels alors que trop
souvent l'outre-mer est encore
insuffisamment prises en compte
tout semble démontrer que le ministère
chargé de l'outre-mer et la délégation
générale à l'outre-mer ne dispose pas
réellement de cette autorité au sein du
gouvernement pour jouer pleinement ce
rôle de coordination et de pouvoir peser
suffisamment dans les arbitrages
interministériels or l'outre-mer a
besoin d'une administration centrale
solide qui puisse l'accompagner vers son
avenir
une administration qui disposent de
véritables capacités d'évaluation et de
prospective une administration qui soit
même d'effectuer l'analyse évoqué
précédemment de l'efficacité des
dispositifs spécifiques
faveur de l'outre-mer la réforme déjà
effectué de la délégation générale à
l'outre-mer n'est pas satisfaisante et
n'a pas atteint ses objectifs
rattaché au ministère de l'intérieur
elle ne dispose pas de l'autorité
suffisante pour assurer sa mission de
coordination interministérielle
de plus ces effectifs ne paraissent pas
adaptés aux missions qui devraient être
les siennes en termes de conception de
pilotage d'évaluation et de coordination
il faut aller plus loin et d'ailleurs je
rends hommage à notre collègue mention
dans son excellent rapport sur cette
question
votre commission des lois plaide donc
pour le rattachement direct au premier
ministre de l'administration centrale de
l'outre-mer sous forme d'une délégation
interministérielle d'une mission
interministérielle ou mieux encore dans
secrétariat général à l'outre-mer à
l'instar de secrétariat général aux
affaires européennes cette remise à
niveau est particulièrement urgente pour
accompagner les profondes évolutions en
cours outre mer l'outre-mer on ne le
dira jamais assez est une chance pour la
france
nous ne devons jamais l'oublier et
encore moins quand nos compatriotes
ultramarins ont besoin de nous et ils
ont besoin de nous aussi votre
commission des lois sous réserve de ces
observations d'un avis favorable à
l'adoption des crédits de la mission
outre m merci monsieur le rapporteur
après la présentation des rapporteurs la
parole est maintenant à notre collègue
jean etienne antoinette un parenté au
groupe socialiste
vous avez la parole vous chers collègues
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues lorsque je lis le budget
qui nous est soumis aujourd'hui
d'aussi loin que ma mémoire politique se
le rappelle il me vient un constat
navrant et pathétique
un constat que tous les apparents
rebondissements de l'histoire n'arrive
plus à masquer offert pour l'outre-mer
rien de nouveau sous le soleil
cette période de l'année au sens mal un
de ces moments d'un long feuilleton
télévisé dont on pourrait rater quatre
ou cinq épisodes sans rien perdre du fil
de l'intrigué
il ya une change en vérité toujours à la
même période
pratiquement devant les mêmes collègues
reprend les chiffes et toujours on
retrouve les perpétuelles d'opposition
entre le discours insistant sur le coup
de l'outre-mer pour la france et un
autre
naïf qui présente ces territoires comme
une chance pour la république
que sommes-nous donc exactement que sont
vraiment les autres maires pour la
france juste un terme trop lents dans la
liste des sujets à traiter au parlement
et qui agace les rapporteurs de la
commission des finances
juste le prix à payer par la france est
il si élevé pour pouvoir se vanter
d'être la deuxième puissance maritime du
monde ou de posséder la plus belle
réserve de biodiversité des pays
d'europe ou encore le port spatial de
l'europe j'ai suivi le débat sur le
budget de l'outre-mer en loi de finances
pour 2009 fin 2008 déjà très contesté
par la pole au mans terre ultramarins
j'ai suivi la crise sociale de 2009
commençait déjà en guyane fin 2008 puis
j'ai suivi le vote en urgence de la
lodeom et encore les états généraux de
l'outre-mer et en faire le 6e homme
j'ai entendu discours annonce engagement
espoir et j'ai vu la réaffirmation au
sein de la population guyanaise du
contrat qui lie la république et ses
territoires périphériques espoir qui
s'est même traduit en janvier 2010 par
un vote des martiniquais et des guyanais
pour un métier de ses bases département
dans la république sous le même régime
en vigueur de l'identité législative
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas le plus
sur titan cynique le dit ne dit-il pas
les promesses n'engagent que ceux qui y
croient
la vérité est bien là qu'il s'agisse de
la loom de la halle aux pommes de la
lodeom la loi de finances aime bien des
voiliers sinon défaire presque sitôt ce
que les lois pour l'outre-mer
parviennent péniblement à essayer de
faire aujourd'hui en à fond on atteint
le fond du puits
kkr pire de que tous deux au
gouvernement qui n'écoute pas la rue et
ce n'est pas moi qui le dit dès lors
qu'il s'agit de l'outre-mer il n'écoute
bien que la rue ont fait un exagérons
rien seulement du moins qu on s'écrit
menace les intérêts politiques et
commerciaux notoirement inéquitable et
qui lui sont particulièrement lié et
c'est donc ce cas là on promet tout ce
qui peut calmer la foule
on peut même se dépêcher de l'inscrire
dans une loi mais une one est un acte
majeur des voiliers dès lors une recette
miracle
ne serait-il pas aussi tout à fait est
considéré de diminuer les recettes de
l'état
le temps de les publier les décrets en
particulier si l'on se donne beaucoup de
mal à laisser un peu traîner les choses
la prochaine loi de finances sera venu
la russe sera calmée et l'on pourra
reprendre tranquillement ce qu'on avait
donné et même plus
lorsque j'analyse le projet de loi de
finances en général et le budget de la
mission outre-mer en particulier pour
ceux qui apparaissent sur le scénario
d'un mauvais feuilleton indigne d'un
état démocratique c'est le renoir de ses
valeurs le déni de ses propres
engagements et le mépris pour les
citoyens des déjà vulnérable que l'on
abuse de la sorte alors non aujourd'hui
je ne vais pas rentrer dans la bataille
des chiffres du budget 2011
nous le savons tous il diminue budget
que lui-même doit renvoyer au bilan de
la lodeom et donc un nouvel exemple des
inconséquences de ce gouvernement
aujourd'hui je ne veux pas refaire le
procès d'une défiscalisation qui a été
privilégiée au détriment de l'aide
budgétaire une structuration véritable
des filières de développement économique
et qui dévoile aujourd'hui toutes ses
limites
aujourd'hui je ne veux pas m'appesantir
sur la manière dans le gouvernement d'un
les faits
ne prendre aucun compte des actuelles
conditions de logement des ultramarins
sur la propre territoire ni sur les
problèmes de la formation de la jeunesse
de l'emploi et du développement
économique
nîmes interdit sur les quinze mille
foyers qui en guyane vivront encore pour
un temps indéterminé sans avoir accès à
l'électricité
juste à côté de la base où sont lancés
pourtant les vecteurs ariane et bientôt
vega et soyouz
aujourd'hui je voudrais poser la
question du projet du gouvernement qui
sous tend tout cela qu'elle est il ce
projet à mon sens il est vide il sonne
creux
il se pare des oripeaux du changement
institutionnel pour mieux masquer son
manque de contenu et son absence totale
de perspectives sans mise en faisant
taire davantage je vais plutôt me
projeter dans l'avenir et tenter de
parer ou d à c ur et quelques secondes
mouche en effet avec une projection en
effet en ces temps où l'on annonce la
rigueur je m'attache à rechercher de
nouvelles ressources pour les
collectivités territoriales d outre-mer
et plus particulièrement de la guyane je
verrai donc le moment venu à travers
l'accueil réservé à mes abonnements
jusqu'où la volonté de son gouvernement
de mettre en péril en réalité le
développement des outre mer en fermant
toutes les écoutilles en brouillant
toutes les pistes
aujourd'hui j'ai juste envie de vous
poser une question une seule
si vous ne vous pouvez faire davantage
avec d autres au maire de grasse de
grâce au moins ne nous empêchait pas en
plus de faire ce que nous pouvons avec
ce que nous avons est donc
principalement avec nos ressources
naturelles et nos moyens humains
merci merci mon cher collègue
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue denis detcheverry pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique
social et européen
salut delhi avait la parole mon cher
collègue
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
rama mise vous nous présenter un projet
de budget en diminution sensible soit
compte tenu de la situation financière
de l'état on peut effectivement penser
que des efforts sont indispensables et
que chacun doit y contribuer et compris
l'outre-mer je suis d'accord à condition
que le remède ne soit pas pire que le
mal est qu'à terme cela ne coûte plus
cher au cours de ces deux dernières
années on a beaucoup entendu parler de
l'outre-mer parfois sur un fond
d'inquiétude à travers des
manifestations bruyantes des populations
locales ou sur un ton bien plus positifs
comme avec les états généraux de
l'outre-mer qui ont mis en exergue
non seulement les problèmes de nos
territoires mais aussi nos possibilités
de développement car existe aujourd'hui
le gouvernement aussi décidé que l'année
2011 serait l'année des outre-mer je ne
peux que m'en réjouir
au même moment je suis parfois étonné
voire inquiet de certaines réalités
décisions auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés on entend régulièrement dans
les discours l'évolution que l'évolution
de l'outre-mer passe obligatoirement par
sa valorisation
la valorisation de son de son patrimoine
maritime environnemental qui place la
france je rappelle au deuxième rang
mondial par la valorisation aussi de sa
biodiversité qui représente quand même
10 % de la biodiversité mondiale ainsi
que par son intégration géographique en
favorisant les coopérations régionales
j'avais totalement ce programme comme
beaucoup de mes collègues ultramarins
une question me taraude comment y
parvenir
avec des réductions budgétaires comment
faire plus avec moins
c'est ma question certes il est possible
d'optimiser les dépenses certainement
avec une meilleure gestion
il faut rester réaliste là alors que les
objectifs affichés dont les états
généraux sont ambitieux donc difficile à
atteindre avec de telles restrictions
elles pourraient devenir de vaines
déclaration autre source d'inquiétude la
place de l'autre mère dans la politique
européenne
nous savons aujourd'hui que l'union
européenne s'apprête à signer des
accords de libre-échange avec le canada
ou même avec certains états d'amérique
du sud
malheureusement les territoires des
zones concernées ultra marins n'ont
nullement été associé aux négociations
d'où cette question quid de cette
coopération régionale et plus
généralement quelle est la place
réservée à l'outre-mer dans la politique
économique européenne
à saint pierre et miquelon malgré mes
propositions pour dynamiser pérenniser
les relations et échanges avec le canada
les accords de coopération signés en
1994 n'ont toujours rien apporté en
matière économique
je maintiens ce que je vous ai dit
madame la ministre
la coopération régionale ne pourra
exister que si la politique nationale y
croit et s'y attellent sérieusement les
récents contacts que j'ai pu avoir avec
les provinces du canada atlantique me
rapporte que cette coopération à
laquelle ils se sont intéressés
ces dernières années leur somme
impossible à mettre en tellement il ya
d'obstacles au montage des dossiers
en effet du fait de notre petite taille
certaines compétences incontournable
font défaut localement je les dis et je
le répète
madame la ministre ne pouvant assumer à
tous les niveaux l'autonomie que nous
confère l'article 74 de la constitution
j'en profite pour parler de la gestion
de la tnt à saint père me campi à
travers les médias nous font rayonner
sur le canada qui risque de mettre fin à
ce rayonnement ainsi qu'à celui de la
france auprès de nos amis canadiens
initialement prévu pour offrir un accès
gratuit
un plus grand nombre de chaînes avec une
meilleure qualité de réception de son
image l' inverse peut se produire à
saint pierre et miquelon en effet
l'arrivée de la tnt est imposée chez
nous avec un cryptage des chaînes dont
peut-être la chaîne locale
nous ne pourrons donc plus diffusée sur
tout le canada comme nous faisons
actuellement et depuis bientôt 11 ans où
nous avons au canada où nous avons
pratiquement 600 mille téléspectateurs
potentiels
en outre la population devra aussi
investir dans des décodeurs onéreux ce
qui va quelque peu à l'encontre du
principe de gratuité de
de la tnt coût qui sera difficile à
assumer surtout pour les retraités qui
ne sont pas bien prises en compte depuis
quelques années je pense aux petites
retraites
on en a parlé à plusieurs reprises
surtout que saint pierre et miquelon se
trouve comme vous savez dans une zone
dollar donc subi en même temps une
inflation donc nos seniors qui se
retrouvent avec des retraites de misère
pour entrer difficilement se payer ce
genre de 2,2 de télévision autre
inquiétude madame l'amener ici il ya un
an dans ce même ici que j'obtenais votre
promesse pour la mise en place à saint
pierre et miquelon de l'aide au fret à
destination des petites entreprises
exportatrices de l'archipel notamment
nous attendons toujours la mise en
application de cette mesure dans
l'économie locale à crucialement besoin
pour avoir une chance d'être compétitive
qu'en est il aujourd'hui
revenons à 2011 à l'heure où je vous
parle je ne sais pas comment cette année
des outre mer se déroulera
comment se traduira dans les faits que
ce soit sur le terrain ou dans
l'hexagone les parlementaires
ultramarins que nous sommes n'ont à ce
jour pas été associés au projet par
l'état j'espère year notamment une
remise en valeur de l'incroyable
biodiversité de l'outre-mer à la fois
auprès de nos compatriotes
métropolitains ainsi que de nous voisins
géographiques respectifs
même les ultramarins ont besoin de
découvrir ou redécouvrir leur
environnement après avoir appris que
saint pierre et miquelon avait été
oublié par certaines instances
nationales j'ai récemment entrepris de
faire connaître la richesse de la
biodiversité de mon archipel auprès des
ministères de l'outre-mer de l'écologie
de la recherche et enseignement
supérieur supérieur ainsi que du
conservatoire du littoral de la
fondation pour la recherche sur la
biodiversité de la chance des aires
marines protégées de france nature
environnement
j'espère que désormais nous seront
prises en compte pour l'avenir
dans le cadre de cet environnement à
saint pierre et miquelon comme vous
pouvez le constater madame la ministre
je suis inquiet très inquiet
pouvez-vous me rassurer en répondant à
ces questions dans l'avenir de
l'outre-mer et celui particulièrement de
céramique en dépend je remercie
merci mon cher collègue la parole est
maintenant notre collègue madame joly
tas
hoarau groupe communiste républicain
citoyen sénateurs du parti de gauche
la parole mes chers collègues
monsieur le président madame amis niché
à collègues
alors que 2011 se veut l'année des
outre-mer à l'occasion de laquelle
serait fait la promotion de nos
territoires année pendant laquelle nos
diversités nos richesses en termes de
culture institutions développement
durable économie et entreprises seront
mises en lumière force est de constater
que le budget de cette même année fait
fi de ses atouts pis encore exacerbe nos
problèmes nos difficultés
à l'instar des autres dom et de
l'ensemble du territoire national la
réunion subit les effets de la crise
monétaire et financière est une crise
structurelle
nous avons assisté au début de l'année
dernière aux manifestations de cette
crise structurelle lors des mouvements
sociaux ayant secoué une des parties une
partie des outre-mer et sur lesquelles
je ne reviendrai pas aujourd'hui
cette double crise affecte profondément
durablement et peut-être inexorablement
si rien n'est entrepris dès maintenant
les sociétés ultramarines plus
qu'ailleurs les ménages subissent de
plein fouet la hausse du chômage
cette augmentation a même taux de
chômage la réunion un triste record
celui du plus élevé de toute l'union
européenne soit 29 % si l'on peut
comprendre que les ménages se trouve
alors dans une situation financière
critique
expliquant la hausse de l'endettement
plus qu'ailleurs les entreprises
inscrites dans un tissu économique déjà
fragile ne pourront résister à ces
crises
conjugués aux récentes mesures et
réformes gouvernementales ou aux aléas
électoraux avec la fin des grands
travaux la réunion le btp a perdu en
l'espace d'un an 22 % de ses effectifs
plus qu'ailleurs les collectivités
rites orial sont confrontés au besoin de
rattrapage en équipements et
infrastructures et à une forte demande
sociale alors que concomitamment leurs
ressources financières diminuent pour
des observateurs réunionnais cette
double crise aura à terme de graves
conséquences
je cite la revue perspectives
économiques de la réunion dans les
années qui viennent
la réunion va traverser une crise
majeure identique aux deux ou trois
grandes crises qui ont façonné son
histoire depuis le début du peuplement
celle-ci ressemblera sans doute beaucoup
à la crise du sucre audi du 19e siècle
fin de citation telles sont les
perspectives auxquelles vous nous
condamnez alors que des solutions autres
émises par les ultramarins vous ont déjà
été présentés d'eux-mêmes l'opinion
publique réunionnaise est inquiète
pessimiste pour l'avenir 81% considèrent
le chômage comme la préoccupation
majeure
76 x s'entraînent une dégradation du
pouvoir d'achat 70 % pensent que la
situation économique est mauvaise
ces indicateurs datant d'août 2010 sont
à leur plus bas niveau jamais recensé
jusqu'ici le gouvernement n'a pas
toujours sous-estimé la situation
ultramarines ne serait ce que dans les
discours ou dans les intentions ainsi
nous avons eu l'astra comme stratégie de
croissance pour l'outre-mer présenté par
votre piètre prédécesseur yves jégo il
ya plus de deux ans on nous annonçait
que le président de la république était
selon le rapport de présentation je cite
le panther d'une nouvelle vision de
l'outre-mer fondé c'est une volonté de
croissance durable de doter les
économies ultramarines de la capacité da
pour vanter les grands défis de l'époque
en fondant la croissance de chaque
territoire sur ses singularités
fin de citation et pop et que pour de
telles ambitions aussi louables
unanimement soutenu en attendait que le
budget de l'outre-mer pour 2009 2012
allait connaître une progression
exceptionnelle
ensuite il y a eu la lodeom les états
généraux le conseil interministériel
pour l'outre-mer du 6 novembre 2009
visant les mêmes les mêmes objectifs
nous nous attendions donc à des mesures
un budget à la hauteur de ses bus
malheureusement ces intentions ne sont
pas suivies d'effet kt 21 mois après
l'adoption de la lodeom et un an après
le ciom certaines dispositions manquent
à l'appel où sont les mesures de lutte
pour réglementer le fonctionnement du
marché et la concurrence les prix et
fait baisser ainsi le coût de la vie ou
et le développement des productions
locales promis avec le développement
endogène quels sont les objectifs du
gouvernement les moyens qu'il propose de
mettre en oeuvre pour favoriser
l'association régionale dans la lodeom
il était prévu que les compagnies
aréiennes vous transmettre avant le 1er
septembre 2010 un rapport sur leur
politique tarifaire ou est ce rapport
madame la ministre
il en est de même de l'étude relative à
l'octroi de mer il est prévu en 2011
la publication par le gouvernement d'un
rapport indiquant les mesures qu'il
entend prendre ou proposés pour répondre
à la situation financière des communes
d'outre-mer dont l'idylle capital jugé
préoccupant du fait de la particularité
de la matière fiscale
où en est ce rapport à ces
questionnements qui restent en suspens
j'ajoute s'ajoutent pardon un budget
aujourd'hui en diminution pour les
outre-mer est de fait un désengagement
du gouvernement bien que vous appliquez
madame la ministre à soutenir que tel
n'est pas le cas
ainsi les crédits de l'état pour
l'outre-mer s'élevant à 16 milliards
d'euros subissent une baisse de 150
millions d'euros en autorisations
d'engagement ou de 300 millions d'euros
de crédits de paiement
ceux de la mission outre-mer diminue par
rapport à 2010 de 0.55 pour les
autorisations au sens pour les
autorisations d'engagement et de 2,28 %
pour les crédits de paiement
cette mesure drastique n'épargne aucun
domaine
même les secteurs névralgiques
considérés comme prioritaires par la
lodeom
ainsi concernant le logement social
vous maintenez l'illusion de crédit
constants quand les crédits de paiement
ne cesse de diminuer
vous nous annoncez madame la ministre
des crédits de 274 millions d'euros en
autorisations d'engagement pour 2011 et
ce jusqu'en 2013 alors que conjointement
les crédits de paiement diminue de 21
millions d'euros de 2010 à 2011
or vous n'êtes pas sans savoir le besoin
urgent de logements sociaux dans les dom
à la réunion vingt-deux mille six cents
familles sont dans l'attenté d'un
logement social
tous les ans sur les 6500 nouveaux
ménages plus de 70 % relèvent du
logement social
cette année tout l'allèle pays affectés
à la réunion a été utilisé pour la
construction de 3000 logements 2000
logements supplémentaires auraient pu
être livrée si la demande d'une rallonge
de 20 millions d'euros avait été accepté
en outre quelques mois seulement après
la l'autre l'adoption de la lodeom les
bailleurs sociaux vous ont alerté sur
les problèmes de la mise en application
de la défiscalisation
lors de votre rencontre en novembre
dernier vous avez annoncé la rédaction
d'une nouvelle circulaire pouvez vous
madame la ministre nous assurer que
cette dernière verra le jour très
prochainement et mettra fin aux
incertitudes juridiques aux obstacles
administratifs freinant l'instruction
des dossiers en attente d'agrément
fiscal bercy est il prêt à clarifier les
modalités de financement du logement
social par la défiscalisation qui doit
rester un complément la lvi et non se
substituer à elle le fera fut se voient
appliquer le même traitement
32 5 millions d'euros en autorisations
d'engagement mais seulement 25,7
millions d'euros en crédits de paiement
idem pour la résorption de l'habitat
insalubre le risque de voir l'état
contracté des dettes auprès des
opérateurs du logement est bien présent
aucun secteur n'est épargné par cet
abaissement de
crédit dans le programme emploi autres
maires les crédits de paiements destinés
au soutien aux entreprises diminuent de
1,7 pour cent jusqu'à hier il était
question que les contrats aidés subiront
eux aussi une coupe sévère puisque le
gouvernement avec assurance et
aveuglément décide de baisser leur
financement de plus de 40 millions
d'euros sur un an et de 100 millions
d'euros sur deux ans mais de passage à
la réunion
vous annonciez 1800 contrats
supplémentaires est-ce pour la fin de
cette année ou poids 2011 où jean ce
jusqu'à 2014
cet assèchement budgétaire est également
dû au rabotage la défiscalisation des
investissements productifs réalisés
outre mer représentant un crédit pour
l'état de plus de 300 millions d'euros
pour l'année 2011
lors des débats à l'assemblée nationale
sur ce même texte
vous avez rappelé l' annonce du
président de la république dans la
convention outre-mer de vouloir corriger
les effets d'aubaine de la
défiscalisation qui selon le
gouvernement doit se faire par des
mesures radicales au risque de voir la
disparition d'une filière porteuse
d'emplois d'innovation d'ambition
environnementale etc
je veux bien sûr parler du
photovoltaïque
tout cela madame la ministre nous pousse
à nous interroger sur l'efficacité des
mesures classiques utilisés jusqu'à
présent pour tenter de résoudre nos
problèmes
ne sommes nous pas arrivés à la fin d'un
cycle où les méthodes classiques un peu
plus ou un peu moins de défiscalisation
apparaissent totalement inopérante
même si votre budget ne baissez pas et
qu'il augmentait de 5 à 10 pôles ou du
poisson ou plus ce qui n'est évidemment
pas le cas
est ce pour autant que nos problème
aurait été résolu
aussi madame la ministre le moment
n'est-il pas venu de réfléchir un autre
mode de développement poitou l'outre-mer
tels sont madame la ministre
les règles heureusement que je voulais
formulées à l'occasion du débat sur le
budget en outre-mer il est évident que
cela ne pousse pas à l'optimiste et à la
confiance
et comme le mot
mesures de rigueur perdureront encore au
moins trois ans on comprend l'inquiétude
qui s'empare de la population et des
jeunes en particulier
de plus en plus en proie au désespoir et
à la fenêtre
merci mes chers collègues mes paroles et
maintenant notre collègue louis constant
fleming pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
la parole mon cher collègue c'est le
président madame la ministre madame
messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues
les documents mis à disposition dans le
cadre de ce débat budgétaire nous donne
la mesure de l'effort budgétaire par
habitant et par collectivité d'outre-mer
qui doit être consenti par l'état en
cet effort est très inégale allant de
177 à 12400 41 euros par habitant selon
le cas une telle disparité n'en soit
rien pour surprendre
il convient de prendre en compte la
situation de chaque collectivité
d'outre-mer force est de constater
madame la ministre
l'anomalie que ce document ebook et vous
kiffez pas faire paraître en ce qui
concerne la collectivité de saint martin
pour celle-ci l'appartenance à la nation
va se traduire par un effort de
solidarité budgétaire de seulement 6 188
euros par habitant en 2011 sans doute
c'est martin dispose-t-elle désormais
d'une compétence fiscale lui permettant
de collecter des ressources propres
mieux appropriée à ses besoins
mais la polynésie française mayotte
saint pierre et miquelon wallis et
futuna la nouvelle calédonie dispose
également et depuis depuis beaucoup plus
longtemps de la compétence fiscale
l'effort de solidarité nationale et
pourtant entre 5 et 20 fois supérieure
il faut me direz vous pour mesurer le
soutien apporté à une collectivité prend
en considération le niveau de revenus de
ses habitants
mais c'est à l'évidence ce qui n'est pas
fait pour saint martin à propos de
laquelle perdure une image de paradis
fiscal totalement contraire à la réalité
une réalité largement imposée par une
évolution démographique trop ignorée
c'est martin madame la ministre s'était
6000 habitants en 1980 mais
officiellement 35 mille aujourd'hui et
plus probablement 40000 ce
bouleversement démographique n'a
nullement été due à un afflux massif
d'amateurs fortunés de villégiature
tropicale mais bien plutôt un émigration
régionales
posés par la misère l'insuffisance de
soins de formation ou des sports de
travail et toutes les calamités liés au
sous développement dans la situation
haïtienne nous donne le désolant exemple
je suis obligé de rappeler que c'est
l'état compétents en matière
d'immigration qui en 1992 à régulariser
la situation de milliers d'étrangers qui
ont de surcroît profité du regroupement
familial
la commune de saint martin a dû ainsi
faire face à une augmentation massive de
la population qu'il a fallu prendre en
charge tant sur le plan de la santé que
sur le plan scolaire sans oublier bien
sûr leur logement sur une population
estimée à 40 mille personnes il ya
aujourd'hui près de dix mille enfants en
âge scolaire la collectivité de saint
martin ger 16 groupe scolaire maternelle
et primaire et depuis le 15 juillet 2007
trois collèges un lycée un annexe lycées
et s'apprête à construire un nouvel
établissement collèges lycées en ppp le
résultat statistique madame le ministre
que la commission européenne vient
encore de constater c'est que ça
marchait appartient à celles des régions
de l'union européenne qui sont les moins
le moins favorisés ou les niveaux de
revenu par habitant est inférieur à 75%
de la moyenne européenne où le taux de
chômage particulièrement élevé pour les
régions d'outre-mer se trouvant dans une
situation comparable madame le ministre
des forêts nationales de solidarité
budgétaire est en moyenne 8 fois
supérieure l'oubli par la république et
ses services de cette partie deal du
nord de la caraïbe caisse et martin
n'est pas madame le ministre une
nouveauté les saint martinois ils sont
accoutumés
ils ont eu le courage d'en tirer la
conséquence institutionnel qui
s'imposait en votant pour le nouveau
statut d'autonomie qui leur étaient
proposées
les saint martinois espérait cependant
de la part de l'état un accompagnement
attentif et résolue des premiers pas de
la nouvelle collectivité sur la voie de
la responsabilité
cette attente madar le ministre a été
largement déçu la mise en oeuvre du
nouveau statut de ces martin n'a fait
l'objet ni de la préparation soigneuse
qui eux étaient nécessaires ni des
efforts de mise à niveau que les
décennies de négligence avait rendu
indispensable du jour au lendemain la
collectivité s'est trouvé privé de
moyens indispensables à son
fonctionnement privation de l'ain
pourtant moyens de financement des
dépenses communales qui était la
ressource d'octroi de mer privation de
la garantie des douzièmes provisoires en
matière d'impôts directs locaux dont
dépendent les équilibres de la crise de
trésorerie d'une collectivité locale
certaines imposition tels que la taxe
d'habitation n'ont pu être conservés
faute d'anticipation des adaptations
nécessaires des outils informatiques les
compensations financières prévues par la
loi statutaire de 2007 n'ont pas été
assurés
le plan de rattrapage en matière
d'équipements publics prévus par la même
loi organique n'a jamais vu le jour
la liste complète des dysfonctionnements
qui ont accompagné la mise en oeuvre du
nouveau statut de la collectivité de
saint-martin serait trop longue madame
le ministre pour le cadre de cette
intervention
c'est martin cependant on éprouve
aujourd'hui les effets alors que la
collectivité les contribuables saint
martinois ont fait des efforts
considérables à la fois de modération de
la dépense publique est de mise en place
et d'acceptation d'impôts nouveaux
l'impréparation du changement statutaire
a conduit à une situation de
déséquilibre de trésorerie et de
déséquilibres budgétaires qu'avait
annoncé la mission de l'inspection
générale des finances et de l'inspection
générale de l'administration diligentée
à l'initiative de la collectivité elle
même c'est martin demande en conséquence
à l'état madame le ministre
une répartition de l'effort de
solidarité nationale en faveur des
collectivités d'outre-mer qui lui soit
moins défavorable une plus grande
vigilance à l'égard de ses besoins
spécifiques
un meilleur engagement des services
publics dans l'accomplissement des
missions qui sont les leurs c'est martin
demande surtout le simple respect de ses
droits
l'un de ses l'un de ceux-ci prévue par
la constitution de la république
réaffirmé par la loi organique
statutaire et que tout transfert de
compétences s'accompagne du transfert
des moyens permettant l'exercice de
celle ci la collectivité de saint-martin
madame le ministre doit exercer les
compétences qui étaient celles de la
commune de s'adapter
celle-ci bénéficier pour cela de
l'importante ressources que représentait
je les ai rappelés une fraction du
produit de l'octroi de mer collectés en
guadeloupe
je conçois fort bien
ils ne puissent plus être demandée à la
région guadeloupe de poursuivre l'effort
de solidarité qu'elle accomplissait au
profit d'une commune qui était partie
intégrante de son territoire
je ne puis pour autant admettre que le
principe constitutionnel de compensation
financière des transferts de compétences
soit en ce qui concerne c'est martin
passer par pertes et profits
en reprenant son compte en vue du
financement des dépenses de natures
communal auquel la collectivité de
saint-martin ne peut se dérober
l'obligation constitutionnelle à la
pleine compensation d'une charges
transférées l'état contribuera
simultanément au rééquilibrage de
l'effort budgétaire nationale en faveur
des collectivités d'outre-mer dans
laquelle ainsi que je les rats plus au
début de mon intervention
c'est martin est bien loin de trouver le
juste content que commanderait la prise
en considération de sa situation réelle
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues je vous remercie de
votre attention merci mon cher collègue
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
adrien giraud le groupe de l'union
centriste
jamais la parole mon cher collègue
merci messieurs résidents monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues mayotte entre aujourd'hui dans
une nouvelle phase de son développement
à l'occasion prévue en avril 2011 de
notre collectivité au statut de
département d'outre-mer en conséquence
directe de la consultation populaire du
29 mars 2009 qu au mois dernier
la discussion au sein de notre assemblée
du projet de loi relatif au département
de mayotte m'a donné l'occasion de faire
le point par la situation actuelle de
notre collectivité et sur leurs étapes
de son développement économique et
social
avant d'aborder les questions relatives
à l'organisation de ce 101e département
de la république madame la ministre
les sociétés évoluent le besoin de
mayotte ne sont pas ceux d'hier
le gouvernement a souhaité que la
solidarité nationale continue de
s'exercer au mieux des intérêts de
mayotte qui a encore aujourd'hui le plus
grand besoin d'un accompagnement fort de
l'état dans cette phase importante de
son évolution
et dès sa mise à niveau nous demandons
de dans toute la mesure du possible de
prendre en compte dans un premier temps
nos retards dans le domaine notamment
des infrastructures indispensables pour
nos progrès à venir et à savoir les
routes et les voies communes et
communication les hôpitaux et
dispensaires nécessaires à
l'amélioration de la santé fils public
le réseau d'assainissement
j vient une fois de plus la construction
d'un véritable aéroport
répondant à sa conception architecturale
aux attentes tant des élus que de la
population cette question devrait faire
l'objet d'un nouvel examen permettant
autant que possible de rapprocher les
points de vue sur ce projet
particulièrement important pour l'avenir
de mayotte
il est évident en effet qu'un tel projet
doit se fonder sur un consensus aussi
large que possible sans susciter d'une
itil polémique en dépit du cadre
budgétaire national dont je connais
toutes les contraintes et malgré les
efforts déjà faits par l'état
enfin de déserter résorber nos retards
de développement
je souhaite loclois à mayotte d'un
concours financier spécifique destiné à
permettre aux communes mahoraise de
faire face au lou de charge de cette
période de transition jusqu'à
l'installation 2014 de l'organisation
départementale et un entendant bien
entendu l'application progressive de la
fiscalité locale qui leur permettra de
ressources nécessaires à leur
fonctionnement
madame la ministre il me semble
indispensable une formation adaptée soit
portée à plusieurs catégories des
fonctionnaires qui sont déjà à présent
appeler à mettre en oeuvre concrètement
la départementalisation sur le plan
administratif technique et financier
d'autre part je souhaite appeler tout
spécialement votre attention sur l'état
du réseau routier à mayotte ce réseau se
compose de 90 km qu'à 90 km de routes
nationales et 139 km de routes
départementales
la direction de l'équipement est
responsable de la gestion des routes
nationales pour le compte de l'état et
des routes
partant mental pour le compte de notre
collectivité ces routes ont été
dimensionnés à une époque où le trafic
routier était faible
ces axes sont souvent détériorer
d'efforts mais faute de moyens
d'entretien régulier à la suite
notamment des inévitables dégâts
résistance résultant de la saison des
pluies
l'érosion est alors considérable c'est
pourquoi les réseaux routiers se dégrade
rapidement compte tenu également de
l'augmentation importante du trafic des
poids lourds entre les principaux pôles
économiques
quelques aménagements ont été déjà
réalisés tels que la rocade de repérer
en 2002 et deux passes mighty en 2005
pour désengorger ce trafic très intense
partant de ce constat que de lourd
couché
partant de ce constat que des besoins
cruciaux de mer à mayotte en particulier
en terme d'infrastructures
le 13e plan contrat de projet et à
mayotte 2008 2014 a retenu dans son
quatrième axe la mise en oeuvre d'un
aménagement équilibré du territoire à la
création la mer relations et la
sécurisation du réseau routier
le coût prévu pour cette action s'élève
à 20 millions d'euros pour le réseau
national à la charge de l'état 1,5 fin
d'année 2010 un peu plus de 8 millions
d'euros auront été consommés soit la
totalité des crédits ouverts en demie
entre 2009 et 2010 il reste donc deux
millions à honorer pour les prochaines
prochaines années je souhaite sur ce
point obtenir du gouvernement tout toute
assurance sur le respect de ses
engagements si important pour notre
entreprise locale c'est à dire l'emploi
des mahorais
s'agissant de la programmation routière
or ouvrages d'art concernant le réseau
national
les montants d'autorisations
d'engagement se se portent à 4 millions
d'euros par an pour les trois années à
venir
la dernière étude réalisée par le centre
d'études techniques d'équipements
annexes constate que le besoin
d'entretien et de régénération du réseau
à mayotte sont de 15 millions d'euros
afin de permettre le patrimoine un état
sans en modifier les caractéristiques il
s'agit simplement des travaux ayant pour
objet de maintenir ce patrimoine à ce
qui concerne l'amélioration du réseau
routier
les besoins sont estimés à 30 millions
d'euros
sur 70 millions d'euros un peu plus de
11 millions sont actuellement financés
par le contrat projet et à mayotte
près de 20 millions supplémentaires
seront donc nécessaires afin de mettre
le réseau routier en état je
n'insisterai pas davantage sur l'état du
réseau départemental dont on peut
évaluer environ 35 millions d'euros
les désinvestissements sur les
prochaines années pour en assurer la
sécurité et qui peuvent être financés
par les communes mahoraise faute de
moyens madame la ministre voudrait bien
nous apporter des éclaircissements
nécessaires sur l'actuelle des ces
dossiers suivis avec une grande
impatience à mayotte par l'arrêt par la
raison évidente que l'intérêt économique
de ces projets pour les entreprises
rejoint les besoins de la population en
termes de sécurité routière et
l'amélioration des échanges de toute
nature tant à l'intérieur de la
collectivité que dans des relations à
l'extérieur en particulier dans le
domaine du tourisme
en conclusion il est évident qu'elle est
mort et peuvent enfin dans le cadre
départemental consac c'est consacrer
leurs efforts au développement
économique ainsi qu'aux progrès socio
culturel de notre collectivité
la réponse apportée par les marées lors
de la consultation du 29 mars 2009
signifie également que le temps est
désormais venu de tirer les conséquences
de l'évolution politique récente qui
appelle bien évidemment de vigoureuses
actions de la frappe âge initier et
accompagner par l'état lors de la
discussion budgétaire de l'an dernier
j'ai eu l'occasion d'appeler l'attention
du gouvernement sur nos priorités car
nous avons bien dit que le proverbe que
paris n'ait ses preuves que fait
construire en un jour mais il s'agit
pour nous l'urgence économique sociale
qui s'appelle l'éducation modernisation
foncière logement
j'essaie pouvoir compter sur la ville il
l'avij vigilance du de l'engagement du
gouvernement pour élever de tels défis
avec mayotte
permettez moi de rappeler une fois
encore que mayotte a depuis longtemps
formulé le voeu d'accéder au statut de
région ultrapériphérique de l'europe
communautaire au même titre que les
actuels départements d'outre-mer madame
la ministre
les marchés attendent beaucoup de votre
action je sais que vous saurez vous
serez le souci de les décevoir
madame la ministre mais sur le président
mes chers collègues je vous remercie de
votre bienveillante attention
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
richard tu es yava pour apparenté au
groupe socialiste
pour cinq minutes
la parole sur le président madame la
ministre
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues mes collègues
précédent ayant déjà commenté largement
les crédits de la mission outre-mer ge
ne m'appesantirai guère davantage compte
tenu notamment du temps qui m'est
imparti
concernant d'autres dispositions du plf
2011 qui touche à l'outre-mer je salue
notamment les forces de maintien de la
défiscalisation en faveur du logement
social outre-mer
toutefois je ne peux que déplorer encore
une fois le frein politique donnée à
l'investissement photovoltaïque en
outre-mer déjà débattu la semaine
dernière mais l'arrêt de la
défiscalisation dans ce secteur modéré
certes par les récents débats
parlementaires en épargnant
temporairement les petites installations
pas quand même à l'opposé des objectifs
du grenelle de l'environnement et la
volonté gouvernementale affirmé à
travers la lodeom d'aller vers une plus
grande autonomie énergétique de
l'outre-mer dans le cadre d'un
développement économique endogène même
ce avant que sur le plan énergétique
les territoires ultramarins sont encore
très fortement dépendant des
importations pétrolières avec toutes les
conséquences qui en résultent
la commission d'évaluation risques créés
récemment se penchera sur l'impact réel
de ces défiscalisation en matière
photovoltaïque ce qui offrira une chance
pour la polynésie française de démontrer
l'extrême brutalité de cette mesure dans
ce secteur qui n'a eu qu'une durée de
vie d'une seule année dans notre fenua
par contre dans le secteur émergent des
énergies renouvelables vous savez mieux
que nous madame la ministre que la
nation tout à gagner
à ce que nous outre mer puissent être
des pôles avancées en matière d'énergies
renouvelables à la condition essentielle
et préalable que la priorité aux
intérêts des départements et
collectivités d'outre-mer soit assurée
conformément à la charte des nations
unies ou tout au moins que l'exigence
onusienne émergentes du partage des
bénéfices de la croissance soit
appliquée en faveur des populations
ultramarines concernés en polynésie
française la phase de faisabilité d'une
centrale pilote d'énergie thermique des
mers offshore une puissance de 5
mégawatts est sur le point d'être lancé
nous la soutenons et vous aussi
le système d'air conditionné par
refroidissement à l'eau de mer soit qu
il a été testé pour la toute première
fois avec sue ce succès il y a déjà
plusieurs années et il y alimente
désormais plusieurs établissements
hôteliers devenons le développement de
l'exploitation des énergies marines et
en particulier de l'énergie hydrolienne
fait partie des atouts concurrentiels
dans l'eau pouvant tirer parti en
d'autres termes la puissance d'un état
viendra de la mer les outre-mers
représente 97 % de la surface maritime
française on ne l'est pas assez et la
polynésie représente 49% de cette
surface maritime ultramarines
on ne le répète pas à ces jeux c'est
donc au nom de quel potentiel
je m'exprime devant la nation de plus en
plus les outre-mer français prennent
conscience de leur énorme potentiel
propre endogène et de celui qu'elle
représente
si on les réunit ensemble pour la nation
mais nous ne sommes plus à la fin du 19e
siècle derrière sombre pour une partie
de nos outre-mer né en 1958 dans un
contexte politique de reconstruction
nationale et encore en 1973 au lendemain
du choc pétrolier où la dette publique
de la france
naissance et où l'ange et rêve outre mer
français permettez moi l'expression
quelque peu à la hussarde en 2010 les
lignes ont bougé
la nation doit avoir à se donner les
moyens de ses grandes ambitions
l'outre-mer français en fait-elle partie
on ne peut pas satisfaire tout le monde
c'est vrai mais alors c'est qu'il a
peut-être trop de monde et plus assez de
moyens vous vous trouvez réclame un
accompagnement institutionnel et
financier qui soit cohérent et loyal
suivant leur statut institutionnel leur
histoire propre ou leurs aspirations
respectives ils réclament un partenariat
renouvelé avec un état qui leur
conférerait les outils institutionnels
et les moyens financiers de leur
développement économique endogène ou
bien de leur décollage propre la
nouvelle calédonie s'est brillamment
mais non sans douleur
placé dans cette dernière perspective et
nous la saluons fièrement le jour
viendra j'en suis convaincu madame la
ministre ou la polynésie française sur
la planche
cet envol en toute maturité mais dès
aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons plus
supporter alors et des nouveaux défis
énergétiques thématique finances s'il
diplomatique du 21ème siècle qui nous
attendent de pâtir en silence une
politique nationale anachronique envers
les outre-mer français qui en réalité
est pilotée en filtres à conclure par
les ambitions technologiques d'un lobby
militaro-industriel pensée puissant et
par la rigueur budgétaire de bercy
le véritable paul nous interrompons
cette séance pour suivre en direct le
déplacement nicolas sarkozy le président
de la république et dans le calvados
pour parler médecine de proximité
il est venu à la rencontre des
professionnels et des élus pour évoquer
notamment les problèmes de démographie
médicale en zone rurale la table ronde
qu'il préside vient de commencer on
écoute en direct
chirurgien orthopédiste et débuter
locale il me revient cher président
l'honneur et le plaisir d'animer cette
table ronde sur la médecine de proximité
mais tout d'abord merci de cette visite
et l'honneur tout le pays d'auge et des
mondes votre attachement aux patients
autant qu'aux professionnels de santé et
la firme ainsi tout l'intérêt que vous
portez aux réalisations concrètes et aux
initiatives locales